oh hey sir Sir sir
special delivery of the stabbing nature
hood Oh Jim sham flim-flam baby la
biblia never bro my goodness
that guy has so many accessories I don't
need to stab him the brain he's already
been stabbed hey don't grab me with your
weird hands sprint around hide didn't
see a thing
they have no idea where I went I'm a
stealthy sir no I like how they point
right before they come after me
there is gob okay huh whoa that was way
too close
oh my goodness Hey Dude what's that over
there
oh is that a sound of a tasty beverage
go for it man
are you doing what are you doing that
wasn't even close you [ __ ] no you're
looking at a wall you big goof come on
wait where to go well we're just body go
Hotel where to go where to go where's my
lantern how do I get home get my lantern
what
oh god he's up what the hell I thought
he was dead yeah
boom are you done there's my goddamn
lamp I didn't see it before
oh good Oh No did you senpai don't
notice me right now
oh hi senpai house uh-oh there's no Bo